Peter thank you for an amazing
presentation
can't tell you I've been following the
work of Grand Challenges of canada for
many years it is inspiring its
innovative following work it'sit's
spawned work across the globe so what a
pleasure to hear an incredible and
incisive presentation about your work
what a privilege to welcome you back as
an alum and am I allowed to say my proud
my pride is a fellow torontonian so
thank you very much and thank everyone
here obviously you're going to make the
day we're delighted to have you here I
welcome you on behalf of the entire
school I'll repeat some thanks to the
entire aya leadership for showcasing us
during our Centennial people have
mentioned but I just want to repeat
Chris Beth Alisa and Robert have done an
amazing job making this come to fruition
I hope
I knew our lumps are amazing but boy
when you work with people on a project
like this it's even more incredible
Brian letterer is our deputy dean and
chair of the Centennial committee
there's an entire committee members of
faculty staff and students for planning
events and I don't want to single anyone
out but i will genetic effects thanks
for that wonderful overly gracious and
generous introduction but Jeanette has
been a force of nature envisioning and
spiring organizing creating this so
thank you to that entire group for
making today happen and Marta thank you
so much for being here one of our
greatest alums and supporters or thank
you okay I was asked to give a brief
introduction to the school and that's a
little awkward what do you envision when
I say the word school you probably think
of a building right we sort of have this
connotation of a building but I don't
think of the Yale School of Public
Health like that I think of it as a
vision and Jeanette gave you a vision
and I don't know if it's true every
morning but i would venture to say
almost every morning I wake up with a
vision for a better world that's what
makes me excited about coming to Yale
excited to see the students excited to
see our faculty did you hear the passion
in Jeanette's voice I'm sure she has a
vision i think our students and our
faculty wake up every morning with that
well maybe not every morning they have a
vision to and i'll tell peter i will
talk about the speed the students i'll
show a little video clip later and they
make some comments about students and it
literally almost brings me to tears of
joy when i think of our students they
truly are innovative their creative
they're intelligent they're just the
most wonderful people but let me tell
you let me do now what I was asked to do
and that has introduced you to the
school what is its was telling Peter
last night I came here about nine years
ago and I can't tell you how many of you
not literally you but alumni faculty
students would say I didn't know yell
head of school of public health so I
want to tell you that Yale's
school of public health and tell you
about it one way of thinking about a
school or a vision or an implementation
where we have the vision how do we
implement that one way of thinking of
the schools are alumni Jeanette
mentioned we have five thousand alumni
in every state of the union in 70
countries around the world we have about
250 faculty students across several
degree programs one of the amazing
things about Yale is its rich programs
and the ability to collaborate you've
seen the Centennial theme and you're
going to hear the words collaboration
and innovation over and over and over
again it could not agree more with the
vision that Peter laid out we do all
kinds of research we do all kinds of
scholarship but unless we can innovate
and have that an impact on lives we've
been a total failure and a way to do
that is to collaborate with our
wonderful colleagues throughout Yale
we're a very diverse group forty-two
percent of our students or racial ethnic
minority students and twenty-eight
percent of our students come from other
countries are students don't just study
in the classroom they do internships
that's a requirement and they don't just
do it in New Haven or in Washington they
do it all throughout the world you're
going to see some stories from around
the world in a minute and we have global
research alliances which I'll mention in
a minute formal alliances with Russia
China Brazil Greece and library in fact
I just got back from Shanghai Monday
assigning another agreement with the
president of shanghai jiaotong
university for that I'll describe in a
little bit i'm not going to describe all
the programs i just want to give you a
sense I'm actually I have a CEA winslow
slide too but I'm going to disagree with
CEA he says that public health is the
science and I often say it's not a
science it's a collection of scientists
it's a group of people and I think if
you look at our departments and you
think of the diversity from behavioral
scientists to biostatisticians to
infectious disease experts the
mathematical model errs we bring
together all kinds of expertise people
in this room
medicine engineering we bring together
the best minds we possibly can to solve
the problems that you've heard about it
and that face us this is a synopsis of
our mission did I mention the word
innovation yep as part of our mission
we're multidisciplinary collaboration we
want to create leaders you are leaders
Yale creates leaders we want to create
leaders to solve these problems and not
just to do research not just to do
education but to serve communities we
want to have an impact but I mentioned
CA Winslow yet let me briefly go through
that we all have the requisite slide let
me just go Boop CA Winslow he was a
visionary one thing I wasn't mentioned
he was a bacteriologist in 1915 he had
the vision to how to improve health was
not just bacteriology he had a vision of
the broader social impacts the broader
factors that impact health and he was
truly prescient and the reason i'll
mention that is we really feel a burden
today we look back and we say Winslow a
hundred years ago was this prescient man
who SAT there and the Yale campus and
recognized all these things he
recognized we're going to have to move
beyond bacteriology he recognized we had
to move into communities he recognized
we had to work in Connecticut what our
children going to look back and say what
happened in 2015 were they asleep at the
watch or were they thinking where are we
going in the next century so I'm going
to look back a little bit and then give
you a little book to the forward and
then we're going to have conversations
the design of today is to be interactive
so you're going to hear mostly from our
students faculty and alumni but I just
want to introduce some of it up here you
can read there's some of the Sentinel
events in the history we had a polio
study unit that was created here we did
some of the early cancer reporting in
Connecticut I respected that 1930
Connecticut today has one of the most
impressive cancer registries in the
country and that had its origins a 1930s
these leaders who thought ahead to what
we would need a hundred or seventy years
later in 1946 the actual idea of a
school of public health was launched and
we were one of the first eight schools
in the country it was accredited as a
school of public health you're going to
hear from one of my colleagues about
Dorothy horseman later a path breaker in
medicine so I won't discuss her more now
John Rodman Paul is another noteworthy
scientists in our history and then in
nineteen sixty we became the department
of epidemiology and public health and
the Yale School of Medicine so some of
you may know us as the Department of eph
we still are actually the Department of
eph but we're more now recognized
uniformly universally as the Yale School
of Public Health although we work very
closely and cherish our relationship
with the School of Medicine many of you
have seen 60s College Street which is
the home base for many of us and that
building was designed by Philip Johnson
and it was designed to harbor the Yale
arbovirus research unit which is now
still called the laboratory of
epidemiology and public health that was
built in nineteen sixty four and one of
the people who came here around that
error was max theiler who actually won a
Nobel Prize for his work and the Lasker
Award is actually in the hallway of 60
College Street still and Wilbur Downs is
a figure whose beloved and his legacy
lives on established the Downs
international health student travel
fellowship in 1965 every year we send
students to every corner of the world to
solve the kinds of problems that Peter
was telling you about Peter mentioned
Elvin Feinstein one of the other beloved
iconic professors around here was John
Thompson who added the hospital
administration program John actually has
had an impact on virtually everyone in
this room he developed what is now known
as the diagnostic related groups
strategy on which now all hospitals in
the United States are reimbursed at
systems been refined but he
he was a visionary and an implementer
who saw that and a local figure is
Cornell scotty scott who regrettably is
no longer with us he's one of our alums
and made many many local contributions
and founded the hill health center it's
now in his honor called the cornell
scott hill house center Peter told
stories I did not have the privilege of
knowing Scotty personally I'd met him
and then one thing I did do in 2008 I
had the undesirable I went to his
funeral and I wanted to see here about
this man and honor this man who had done
so much and i have to tell you talking
to his family and his relatives and the
people in the community and hearing how
much of an impact one of our lumps that
had that's the kind of thing we want to
replicate we don't just want the best
science which we have we want to be able
to talk to people in the community to
say this changed my life and Scotty
certainly did just like the needle
exchange program you hear about that
nationally that's to reduce deaths due
to hepatitis and AIDS that idea was
spawned here it was implemented in New
Haven these are public health
individuals who do this kind of work
fast-forward to recent years Susan main
who just left to head the health the
Food Policy Council at the Federal Drug
Administration did path-breaking studies
on skin cancer she actually she's seen
here signing with the governor malloy a
bill to limit adolescent use of tanning
beds which will reduce skin cancer so
again these ideas of taking basic
science implementing it and having a
direct impact on people just to
highlight this idea of collaboration
Peter put up a science article he wrote
I put one here on the cover of science
that is I'm sure you all recognize at
etsy fly and this is an article from
2014 and it was describing the mapping
of the genome of the Tet see fly and you
may say well why is anyone
want to map the genome of the Ted C
flight it's a very complicated
path-breaking activity this could have a
huge impact on African sleeping sickness
which that sleeping the Tet see fly
transmits huge breakthrough it required
this the article in science has a
hundred and forty authors this took a
collaboration of a hundred and forty
scientists in 37 countries so when we
say innovation through collaboration
that's the future we think and Peter
mentioned a bola mentioned a bowl again
we had son we had students listen I
wasn't going to go to library but our
students were in Liberia there in the
front lines they were solving problems
they were helping and you may have you
may not have known it was the Yale
School of Public Health but you're
probably read about mathematical models
that helped Liberia map the epidemic
respond to the epidemic in a much more
effective way than they had been and
evoking more funding throughout the
European Union so it was central work
that did that you've heard a lot about
the centennial I won't review that let
me just give you a couple highlights of
sort of how are we thinking tomorrow's
public health is not my public health
you probably heard about Big Data I'll
describe some alumni are thinking about
Big Data again I told you just got back
from Shanghai we sign an agreement to
establish a by a joint biostatistics
unit with shanghai jiaotong university
together china data from all the
hospitals throughout china to look at
genomics data we have joint teams
looking at innovative cancer solutions
global health at yale my guest says why
actually I was talking to Peter here we
have one of the greatest innovators in
global health when I got here we had a
division of global health with three
faculty members and with all due respect
to Yale there wasn't any formal Global
Health Program at Yale we created a new
division there's an entire program we
see global health is a challenge for all
of us so we bring in
show you every faculty every department
and so on Peter mentioned
entrepreneurships we have established a
program and social entrepreneurship
where we get these incredible students
that Peter was talking about to compete
there's a twenty-five-thousand-dollar
prize and every year I go to the jury
when they award the finalists and they
give you these ideas exactly like Peter
told you I think that's simple ideas
innovative ideas inexpensive ideas they
come up with things that maybe you would
come up with but I wouldn't these are
the students they're thinking a way that
I don't I'll just mention very quickly
if people said what are we not doing
that 10 years from now or a hundred
years from now will feel really really
bad that we were doing one of the
biggest challenges facing us is climate
change and I'm not going to get into a
debate whether it's human-made or not
human-made and so on climate change is
happening and climate change is
affecting our health dramatically and
it's a fealty affecting disadvantaged
populations more and I said you know we
don't have a program in that and so
several faculty got together we've
developed an idea we just got a 2
million grant from the Overlook
foundation and we're starting we're
developing an undergraduate course a
graduate course a research program
fellowships for graduate students we're
going to start working on that in a very
collaborative and innovative way I'm
where I want to keep a semi on schedule
but so I'll just mention i talked about
our interdisciplinary strength I think
you can see here from the day I arrived
I often joke I've never seen a
collaboration that I didn't like I've
gone from school to school gone from
investigator to investigator have
created ties where I could create ties
both in the University Jeanette has been
a key to making links with the community
across different faculties we have an
incredible number of innovative programs
now that draw together different
faculties we offer the most joint
degrees of any professional school near
versity so probably many of you here are
from probably everyone here is from one
of these schools or programs with which
we have a joint degree so if you're one
of the people who said I didn't know
that you had a school of public health
if you were to come back and enroll
today we would try and get you to
collaborate with us on learning how to
solve the kinds of problems that Peter
mentioned we are not just a graduate
school Yale does not have an
undergraduate program but we felt it was
important to engage the best and the
brightest Witch Yale students are I was
going to say you were but you still are
Yale students have enrolled in as many
as forty eight percent of our courses
and over the past couple years they've
accounted for fifteen percent of the
students and our course is over also we
have engaged the undergraduates as well
to reach across to the college in an
educational effort Jeanette when I
arrived Jeanette and I were talking one
day we were both I guess jointly
expressing our frustration of how
science doesn't translate we wanted to
have a bigger impact in our community I
talked about many times I've given
interview as I say I feel a profound
responsibility to my neighbors of my
next-door neighbor got sick I would be
over there helping them I'd be asking if
they needed anything I'd be asked him if
they needed food I be asking as they
needed referral or you know any kind of
help New Haven are my neighbors and we
weren't doing enough Jeanette created an
alliance not a program not a grant but
an alliance with the community called
care it's addressed a range of issues
including by the way the community
health assistance we just did our third
it had never been done before
community-wide face-to-face interview
assessment of the health problems the
needs the challenges throughout New
Haven it's a roadmap for what we need to
do it's a motivator it's a guide it's an
assessment hadn't been done we're there
doing it with rohui jeanette's they are
doing it also doing built environment
food and security
a community engagement I go to the
advisory group meetings I meet with
people from the health care system from
the educational system community
activists community representatives it's
just this amazing collaborative group
that we interact with let me just tell
you quickly about a couple of alumni and
then you'll hear directly from them in a
few minutes pamela sutton wallace class
of 97 just to give you a range a sense
of the range of the kinds of leaders we
produce CEO of the University of
Virginia Medical Center I won't go
through the details here but we indicate
leaders who are running the biggest
health care systems in the country of
the the CEO and the COO of Yale New
Haven healthcare system are graduates of
our system so throughout the country
leaders in this area toshiya Chimaera he
worked at for 13 years of boring angle
I'm he's done very very innovative work
on minimizing drug resistance we do
incredible work I'm mother-to-child
transmission in HIV in a number of other
areas an incredible innovator in
pharmaceutical development he just moved
to Regeneron gretchen van wie she's an
assistant commissioner in the Bureau of
Vital Statistics at New York City
Department of Health and Mental Hygiene
sometimes you get the sense that we're
not directly involved in public sector
public health were very directly
involved a lot of leaders are here
Gretchen's family grew up an art she
became very involved and interested in
having an impact in New York and she's
done incredible work there on consuming
sugared beverages directing health
research evaluation and planning and
harp in Harlem she also oversees the
registration analysis of all births and
deaths in New York City dr. chidiya
Daris you've heard about a bolus several
times we had students on the ground
doing the kinds of not the rapid test
development like Peter talked about
we've done the modeling but dr. yadira
was
the Minister of Health and Lagos and you
probably didn't hear as much about
Nigeria what you did hear about
nigeria's they were much more effective
the students I talked about we're in
Liberia where the problem got out of
control Nigeria did a much more
effective job there's a lot of reasons
for that but we're very proud that one
of our alumni what is that the head of
the Hat was at the helm during that
crisis dr. edith pestana does she's the
administrator of many of you may not
know a program like this exists
environmental justice program remember I
mentioned the impact of the environment
remember how I mentioned it has
disproportionate impact on certain
populations people like Edith care about
that she's in the Connecticut Department
of Energy and Environmental Protection
she looks at the way the impact impacts
on different populations subpopulations
she monitors the site and others to
address environmental inequities and
thinks of ways to address those John
Brownstein you're actually going to hear
a description of him in a minute John is
the epitome of big data and you've
probably heard that Google anticipated
the flu before the CDC did well health
map those I saw a couple people looking
at their cell phones or something or
googling when you take a break at lunch
Google Health map calm and put in some
data if you met you want health map data
provided one of the earliest indicators
of the novel h1n1 virus in 2009 though
he was the first person that was the
first group to identify the emerging
epidemic so some people say it's true
big data is this amorphous kind of
meaningless term this is an example a
big data how it's used and the impact
that can have bedding or is the director
of the Department of International
Cooperation Ministry of Health to
Cambodia just to give you a sense we go
from the local community to the New York
Health Department to Cambodia someone's
monitoring surveillance of disease help
plan the healthcare system there so
that's a six cities and two days
overview of the Yale School of Public
Health as I say I I could talk endless
maybe it already seemed endlessly but I
could talk endlessly but it's to be more
interactive but i also wanted you to
hear more directly the voices of some of
our faculty alumni and students
you
over the last 100 years the Yale School
of Public Health has become one of the
top academic institutions of its kind in
the world providing the essential
leadership to protect and improve public
health locally nationally and globally
through groundbreaking research policy
analysis education and training across
its graduate and professional programs
the school serves diverse communities
with its knowledge and expertise we have
a theme for the centennial it's called
innovation through collaboration and I
think we're at a very vibrant point in
our history where we're very innovative
we're collaborating with a diverse group
of scientists and community members and
we're booming really in terms of science
and the kind of influence we're having
on health throughout the world our
mission began in nineteen fifteen when
public health was still in its infancy
Charles Edward Amory Winslow a
bacteriologist by training launched
Public Health at Yale and over the
course of the following decades the
school and its scientific reach grew
under Winslow's inspired leadership
making enormous contributions that
enhanced and promoted public health
when's lo certainly ought to be
considered one of the fathers of Public
Health the thing Rinzler did was to
accept the notion that if one is to be
educated in anything one must understand
and one must be curious and one was seek
the opportunities to collaborate in the
Yale School of Public Health's early
days there were many other pioneers who
followed in Winslow's footsteps Dorothy
horstmann is a major figure not just at
Yale but in medicine period after all I
think she's probably the first woman who
achieved tenure and a full professorship
here
she is recognized by the national
institutes of health's he was on
committees established research programs
so Dorothy would be a favorite of mine
another was Wilbur downs a renowned
Globetrotter he was known to counsel
students to get outside the classroom
and away from home and travel to
wherever pressing public health and
medical problems existed he became the
inspiration for the Downs international
health student fellowship and since
nineteen sixty six scores of Yale
students have traveled the world to
conduct challenging and innovative
research projects the school's 100-year
history has also been marked by numerous
other renowned faculty these were
committed scientists who work to improve
basic sanitation eradicate polio
understand the transmission of
insect-borne diseases and implement a
needle exchange program in New Haven to
combat hiv/aids this effort was
augmented in 1997 when Michael Merson
who became the school's first official
dean founded syrah the Center for
interdisciplinary research on AIDS at
Yale the organization remains vibrant
and active today continuing its
tradition of innovative research to slow
the spread of the hiv/aids epidemic
others work to improve the health of
senior citizens enhance health care
management and procedures improve birth
outcomes and more recently contribute to
the understanding of the genetic
underpinnings of disease since its
inception thousands of Yale educated
public health alumni have also become
leaders in their fields around the world
often in the most challenging settings
today these alumni include the likes of
arianne currently who digs deep bore
wells in the arid regions of niger to
provide life-giving water to thousands
of people jewel Mullen who leads
hundreds of dedicated professionals at
Connecticut's Department of Public
Health John Brown steam who has
developed an online map that shows
international disease trends and
outbreaks and new Robshaw who is CEO and
senior vice president of Kaiser
Permanente in Southern California it is
educated more than four
thousand public health professionals and
others who work in this extremely
important field it has been the public
health approach that has allowed us to
make huge advances in the prevention of
disease from Ebola to obesity to complex
social problems that result in serious
health consequences the Yale School of
Public Health is helping to lead the way
to healthier lives for all the schools
collaborative approach Foster's
innovative solutions to pressing health
problems around the world in the field
of genomics yale school of public health
researchers are charting the future of
medicine and have been leaders in
developing genetic epidemiology
techniques such as jiwa jiwa stands for
genome-wide association studies and it's
a technique that's used where you can
map a very small segment in the genome
that is associated with a particular
disease or phenotype that you're
interested in vietnam association
studies are really revolutionized the
medicine in the last ten years and
actually started o hero school public
health researchers are using this
genetic data and applying it to help
make improvements in health care and
health outcomes including age-related
macular degeneration asthma and obesity
just what g was in the last few years
we've discovered from forty fifty genes
that are involved in obesity
susceptibility and I think that as we
develop newer techniques as we move
forward maybe we could see making a
bigger impact in that field the human
genome is approximately three billion
base pairs in length and so it's
actually a massive undertaking to to
sequence the human genome my work is
extremely collaborative I don't have a
clinical background and so it really
requires bringing large groups of
investigators together so that we can
get the biological materials that are
needed to actually conduct these studies
this has been an incredible group of
individuals that are coming together to
sort of harness this these whole genome
techniques the future of genetic
medicine is only beginning and the
possibilities for its use in helping to
solve health issues are almost limitless
President Obama just amazed announcement
is precision medicine initiative and
that's really to live individuals DNA
and other information to let her
treatment at the individual level but
we're the future public health my vision
is that will be routinely sequencing
whole genomes of individuals when a
child is born we will know exactly what
mutations an individual carries early in
life and we can then really think about
early interventions
yale school of public health
collaborative approach is also forging
the partnerships that are needed to
improve health outcomes around the globe
with its international partners Yale
experts are developing disseminating and
helping to implement research findings
that improve health care systems in
diverse settings I think when people
think of Uganda they naturally would
think of issues like HIV malaria
tuberculosis the major infectious
diseases which over the past few years
they've made some great strides but what
they're finding in Uganda as in other
countries is the rise of
non-communicable diseases things like
hypertension diabetes cancers we try to
bring people together Yale faculty and
colleagues to think about and
problem-solve on these very specific
issues one global health program at Yale
the global health Leadership Institute
examines existing health care models and
brings essential components to different
settings to create flexible efficient
and effective health systems we modeled
it after an institute that existed in
Uganda that's several years old which is
focused on infectious diseases so we
took that model and we're trying to
replicate it for non-communicable
diseases collaborations the name of the
game in global health you just can't do
it any other way so unless we can
collaborate both within yell across
different departments but then also with
our partners in Uganda you just get
nowhere at the end of the day it's not
just going to one particular medical
solution that's going to address them
but you're going to need a variety of
different groups to be involved and Yale
tries to convene these groups around a
model of really leadership and strategic
thinking where we can think of what is
the best leverage point what could we
invest in in a country like this that
would start the ball rolling towards
being able to deal with their most
difficult problems many other global
health initiatives are underway in
diverse settings around the world
including China Israel south africa and
mexico in brazil dr. albert co and
colleagues are working in the favelas to
address the threat of leptospirosis a
neglected tropical disease that
primarily afflicts the urban poor
you
collaborating with community healthcare
workers in some of the most
disadvantaged neighborhoods in the
United States Yale researchers are
finding community-based solutions and
bridging the healthcare gap to fight
chronic diseases one such program in
Hartford Connecticut dile best is
addressing diabetes almost eighty
percent of individuals with diabetes
live in low and middle income families
so what we decided was to approach the
largest a community clinic in the city
that had a program for Latinos without
adequate insurance to deal with their
type 2 diabetes and we persuaded them
why don't we do this trial whereby we
integrate community health workers as
part of your healthcare management team
and in many ways it was visionary
because this is precisely what the
Affordable Care Act wants to see in
terms understanding much better how to
extend that girl to the community level
it cannot be done by one organization
alone it really has to be through
coalition's of stakeholders all of which
have the common goal of improving the
health and well-being of very
disenfranchised individuals those that
we have left behind Yale public health
researchers are also addressing how to
improve patient recovery quality of life
and chances of survival after treatment
for various forms of cancer through
programs such as lean my area of
research focuses on lifestyle behavioral
change interventions mostly in women
diagnosed with breast and ovarian cancer
we know that lifestyle behaviors such as
weight in physical activity
significantly are associated with
developing those cancers but also
associated with Lauren risk of
recurrence and mortality so we do weight
loss trials and exercise trials compared
to a care that they're normally
ceiving with their oncologist in these
women we observed a marker of
inflammation called c-reactive protein
or CRP and we observed about a thirty
percent decrease in CRP levels with
weight loss and exercise we then want to
bring it out into the community or into
the clinics any men or women diagnosed
with cancer able to come into our clinic
and receive to counseling sessions on
healthy eating exercise yale's work is
shaping cancer treatment and recovery in
the 21st century I would really like to
see weight management or exercise or
lifestyle behavioral treatment a part of
the treatment plan other scientists at
the School of Public Health are
fundamentally shaping the growing field
of disease modeling and how this
mathematical technique can be used to
predict disease transmission and inform
public health interventions for maximum
benefit at the Center for infectious
disease modeling analysis we focus on
evaluating and designing effective
strategies to address public health
challenges mathematical modeling is
simply the use of mathematical and
computational to develop a model for
predictions or the understanding of
disease transmission we're particularly
interested in research that has the
potential to improve public health
policy either domestically or globally
so during the unprecedented ly
devastating at 2014 2015 Ebola outbreak
members of our cinema team traveled to
Liberia to work closely with the
Ministry and we developed an app that
helped to facilitate their community
efforts that were fundamental curtailing
transmission and so while we were in
Liberia our primary focus was working
with community-based efforts to improve
the quality of the data that
being retrieved from their efforts and
also make it more efficient for that
data to be transmitted to
decision-makers the Yale School of
Public Health is a leader in disease
modeling an approach with widespread
promise and potential for public health
scientists such as Ted Cohen Virginia
pitzer forest Crawford and a host of
others further enhanced the school's
growing capabilities we first start by
putting together a multidisciplinary
team medical professional epidemiologist
applied mathematician statisticians
exactly the problem so that we can
develop a model that is robust enough
and that is usable enough to be able to
inform with a high degree of confidence
policy making the effect of the
environment on health is enormous and
Yale public health researchers are
combining cutting-edge scientific
techniques with traditional epidemiology
to understand how human exposure to
chemicals in the environment influence
health outcomes also of growing concern
is how fundamental changes to the
environment itself in the form of warmer
temperatures for instance will impact
communities across the globe in the
coming decades my laboratory is focused
on studying cellular responses to
environmental stressors and dodge
environmental stressors could be from
the UV light which is increased exposure
due to the climate changes and how this
could affect your skin your eyes so in
addition we're looking at various
diseases that can be caused by
environmental conditions and those
include diabetes and also heart disease
my vision for the department's is that
we use systems biology approach is so we
combine the epidemiology along with
genomic approaches metabolomic
approaches and also the toxicology in
our field I collaborate with all people
all over the world just to get to the
correct answers for the population so
public health will play maybe the most
important role
breaking all the sciences together in
terms of predicting and preventing
toxicity and disease through population
in households yards and work
environments and in many of the products
that people regularly use potential
toxic chemicals with serious health
consequences are known to exist there's
a lot of opportunity to prevent or
mitigate or reduce exposures to try to
advance public health so I'm leading an
analysis to look at the combined
exposure to over 50 of these different
chemicals and in my work I collaborate
with top-notch epidemiologists
statisticians chemists to really enhance
the quality and impact of my research
getting accurate and precise exposure
measurements is critical can we
disentangle this mixture and determine
which chemicals are the bad actors that
has implications for regulations
exposure reduction and human health
I think the future of public health is
wonderful and confessing further is in
nursing or in medicine or any of these
things we really need find scholarship
and the will to collaborate with people
outside of our own special area of study
and you see that in public health you do
really see that in public health you
can't neglect the community and expect
the community to thrive so it's not just
about providing medicines it's also
about building models of care it's also
about engaging with health systems it's
also about identifying where the
structural barriers are that you need to
address so these are all sets of skills
that you pick up from a public health
education that you take with you so yes
you know Yale School of Public Health
did prepare me to be a humanitarian
health worker I mean change the way I
looked at things I came from a very
narrow view of what health was and you
know the determinants of health very
narrow view and I left with the much
broader view we have increasing number
of students who want to learn about
health issues that not just only affect
them but citizens across the globe so I
think the new vision that our school has
is to educate our students not just by
giving them the information but for
providing them with the skill set they
need to do problem solving to be true
leaders and be able to address whatever
happens to come up in the next decades
to help so we are talking about critical
thinking problem solving communication
advocacy the kinds of tools that are
needed to solve problems I'm especially
in marginalized populations so I am
really trying to figure out strategies
to sort of get HIV rates down in
specific populations in the United
States and abroad being from Mississippi
I really want to go back to south and
work in
obesity research and helped to make that
whole population a healthier population
I think one of the most important things
that I've gained for my speech is really
a community a community of fertile
researchers my colleagues the students
that I go to school with and this
network really is something that I truly
value because not only have I learned
knowledge but I've learned to see
various issues in the new light just
given the experiences in the backgrounds
of the students and professors that I've
worked in I don't feel like I can't
approach senior faculty members or that
faculty don't know what's going on with
the students everyone is incredibly
involved and that is something that I
that I really love I have alumni mentors
who look over my resume and email me
when they have an article they think
that I would be interested in people who
are top of their field and they want to
talk to me they want to help me they
want to get me started a wise page has
been really good to me you know there's
a lot of talk about ivy leaves being
very pretentious and cutthroat and I've
never felt like that at all wise page in
fact i felt quite the opposite there's a
lot of collaboration people are really
nice and approachable today some 4,500
School of Public Health alumni are also
at work on pressing health challenges in
more than 70 countries around the globe
by putting their training to use in a
variety of capacities whether in
research academics government
administration or private nonprofits our
alumni play a crucial role in improving
public health it's a fields where the
different disciplinary perspectives come
together and produce something
individuals in those disciplines might
not have discovered on their own in that
sense I think it is very much part of
the way I envisioned yells future the
contributions or some of these major
figures in the previous century it
really saw medicine as being a part of
Public Health and once we get a head
around that
I think things will change in a way
which will allow us to make progress
that we need to make while there have
been numerous successes and advances
over the past century the field of
Public Health remains as vital and as
challenging as ever new diseases are
emerging the world is marked by health
and equity adult and childhood obesity
are epidemic diseases are spreading
beyond their traditional borders infant
mortality rates in many parts of the
world remain unacceptably high and the
changing climate is likely to usher in a
host of health challenges that will
disproportionately affect the poor the
Yale School of Public Health through its
expert faculty dedicated students
accomplished alumni and long-standing
collaborative partnerships is poised to
address these and other serious problems
as it embarks on its second century and
continues its work to create a healthier
future for all in Winslow's view good
health and long life where everyone's
birthright when I go through the
building at 60 College Street and I meet
the students and to look at the
enthusiasm and that talent and the
dedication it leaves me with an
incredible sense of optimism and there's
so many smart people who are so
dedicated and working so hard we can't
possibly not have a better future ahead
of us
so I i hope that gave you introduction
to the school and hope you understand
why i'm so enthusiastic and feel so
privileged about being here i want to
thank an prom was the person who did the
overall court the film was produced by
her and Michael Greenwood who is here is
our director of communications oversaw
the entire project and I think he did a
masterful job capturing our spirits or
Michael thank you very much